hey what's up everybody welcome to the
are you garbage comedy podcast please
take a second to subscribe to the
YouTube channel that way you get the
episodes as they come out thanks a lot
welcome to another exciting edition of
ru garbage the show where you find out
if your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is ru garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
trashy or classy
I'm your host H Foley coming at you from
beautiful Astoria Queens where the
bodies are stacking high here during the
pandemic getting a little dicey on the
streets my co-host hot tails out of town
at the first sign of trouble he's coming
at you from an undisclosed location
somewhere in southern New Jersey our
good pal Kippy Kevin James Ryan
everybody cool baby
down here in the Irish Riviera also
known as North Wildwood New Jersey
laying low playing it right even at
Sam's pizzeria uh yeah man happy to be
here thanks for tuning in everybody we
appreciate all the support we appreciate
all the rating reviewing please
subscribe on itunes subscribe on youtube
you can watch the full video thanks so
much as we get this bad boy off the
ground very nice and we have a very very
very very very special guest today we're
so happy that he came to join us on the
podcast I'm gonna read this laundry list
of credits no I was gonna skip over them
do a couple but I said [ __ ] it I'm gonna
take my time and I want everybody to
know so here we go I'm gonna go all the
way back to [ __ ] 2007 Jimmy Kimmel
Live Comedy Central Presents Dane Cook's
tourgasm
we got Gotham comedy live we have Robert
Kelley live at the Village Underground
and then we got cops show inside Amy
Schumer be a man what's your [ __ ]
deal The Tonight Show Starring Jimmy
Fallon two drink minimum week at the
Comedy Cellar
and Gary Gulman to depress all right
then we switch over any acting credits
Kippy and we
that 30 [ __ ] six started out in 1996
with a short called enough already
then he got law and order you got hack
he got good luck Chuck Grand Theft Auto
Law & Order criminal intent the regular
[ __ ] Law & Order Curb Your Enthusiasm
inside Amy Schumer
sirens Nurse Jackie Louie Marin
trainwreck benders 20 episodes on sex
drugs and rock and roll crashing lust
for life and the truth about Santa Claus
gentlemen he is also the owner and
operator of Ryan Katz Network and he's
the host of why kwd ladies and gentlemen
mr. Robert Kelly
you forgot kalter and I'm on a new
podcast called six nights a week seven
o'clock on patreon.com says Robert Kelly
Kathryn Kelly look at me I'm sweating I
know dude I'm getting a little nervous
why why so well you shouldn't sweat
after you read
I took my baby aspirin relax yeah you've
you've been banking on that baby aspirin
for three years I don't think Bobby you
take a baby aspirin every day I I don't
why I don't I'm offended that you assume
you got a dead man walking here you
kidding me you're six years older than
me you're not taking baby listen you're
inside of a actually a place that
probably is regulated heat I'm in a hot
shed and I'm not sweating you look like
you're either you're nervous or you're
dying right now I don't know what's
happening you're sweating it's warm I
mean are you in [ __ ] South Africa
where are you I'm in Queens I'm in a
store you're Queens and I got the window
shut in the heat song for some reason
and I guess I steamy it looks like you
just got out of the shower and it didn't
stick you never let you didn't fully
ever dry off and it just it rolled over
into sweating which is I thought as a
former big guy that's bad news yeah I
hate that too when you put when you put
cream on like my wife after you you're a
fat guy and then it's you start to sweat
and it just forms a layer I've just
filled
yes just film yeah yeah you don't take a
baby aspirin every day what's your
regiment let's start here I don't take
anything you don't think you don't take
fish oil no Bobby's [ __ ] old school I
love it steak a steak and eggs in the
morning and a stick for lunch if you
catch my drift
when's the last time you had a stress
test I had one a year ago after Colin
Quinn had a heart attack and I'm [ __ ]
great
Wow and they don't recommend fish oil
baby aspirin nothing like that for you
no no they [ __ ] said you gotta lose
weight that's it and I just lost 30 35
pounds 35 pounds congratulations see it
in your face for sure yeah buddy yeah
and I liked a little I liked a little
the crooked cop thing you got going on
there and I'm not sweating yeah that's a
big sign I'm just I'm trying to play
this angle like I'm having a [ __ ]
having a stroke over here well I mean
you're [ __ ] scared dude eyes a big
big guy where we're doing a zoom video
chat yeah it's like you're on [ __ ]
that Ninja Warrior show this is your
stress test and you're not you're not
doing well you look like you're doing
this outside in June it's just hot in
here
plus the lights not great I don't know
my ring light see what I like what I
like Bobby goes like Nam they didn't
tell me to do anything they told me to
lose weight and that's what I'm doing
follow these Foley's [ __ ] took the
governor off the car and he's like I
official y'all stop it dude you're going
down the wrong [ __ ] way I tell you
what I look at that baby aspirin is like
my golden parachute anytime I feel a
little bit bad I just pop one of those
I'm good yeah I think I don't think you
[ __ ] up yes thank you thank you Bobby
I think you [ __ ] it up by the
perspiration tester yeah that's not a
mustache that's just sweat actually yeah
you look yes so you look like Gwyneth
Paltrow's legs
that's how shiny you are right now yeah
listen you your face should not be a
dramatically different color than your
neck
when you die I think it's just the
camera it's just it's just it's just the
weight it's just the camera it's not the
500 pounds that he's carrying around
Bobby oh yeah
he is the diabetes filter we can do this
like a half hour
[ __ ] soak in the top I'll have a diet
coke do something take the edge off let
me just grab my defibrillator real quick
just in case [ __ ] [ __ ] go south well
it's so funny because I didn't you're
looking at Rhys background I didn't know
you lived with the Golden Girls
Blanche is a nice lady this is very this
is very down this short so I'm in the
I'm at the Jersey Shore and it's very
distance I mean it's all lighthouses
it's all I'm looking at the sign says
teach a man to fish well spend the
summer on a boat you know what I mean
that's the reclaimed wood they made that
mirror out of a ship that [ __ ] yeah
capsized off shore an example lady went
down I'll make a mirror out of this
there's a lot of light how there's a
lighthouse theme for sure going okay I
like I like follow your set are you are
you dying get it go get a towel what are
you talking about Ali follow you look
horse every time I look at Bobby and
then go back to you you're gonna see is
a nice ring light I'm using like an old
shitty life look buddy I have a lamp
light from my kid's room I swear to God
hang on here we go look is that better I
mean you might want to do that that's a
little better
yeah is that a [ __ ] light from the
20s to Tesla make that light does that
like it so [ __ ] that's like a movie like
Howard Hughes use that's it's an oil
lamp if you must know yeah you know they
make these little LED lights right here
I got one coming I got one coming from
anything okay great cuz that maybe
that's what was making you I mean your
forearms are wet that's disgusting
yeah you're sweaty you're raining over
there but you can see it your shirt
sticking to you
yeah get a fan or something yeah yeah
one of those Japanese fans at the gate
comment just remember boys just to make
a punchline dramatic who you didn't like
that well like this I'm doing that when
we get back to comedy for sure screwing
around here
alright go let's go Buster so Bobby
we're gonna ask you a series of
questions to find out if your garbage
have some inclination that you are and I
just want to say I just wanted to say I
know you grew up in a certain situation
so we're gonna stay away from that and
let me tell all sincerity if you haven't
checked out Robert Kelley's WTF with
Marc Maron do yourself a favor and
[ __ ] check that episode out if you
want to talk about a guy who overcame
adversity to become successful that's
the [ __ ] story you want to hear so I
just want to focus on from like you know
when you were coming up as a comic in
New York and more so your current
situation now with the family
alright yeah just to find out I should
get a drink can I get a drink real quick
cuz this sounds like I mean between your
sweating and this dramatic [ __ ] it's
a light-hearted it's like the generic
cereal that kind of [ __ ]
sets it on like you're gonna go to
Congress I'll be show me where he
touched you show me right now where he
touched you alright Kip you want to
start it off you want me to start it off
okay he's making fun of me look at this
oh my god he does got the college boy
right behind him that's back in garbage
man okay all right the college boy the
college boy in arms reach is a nice
touch that is nice that's garbage though
what is that what is that purple soda
yeah that's uh no sparkling water I
don't have sugar anymore your [ __ ]
tub of [ __ ] I thought you went I saw a
love handle reaching for that
refrigerator well listen I'm not I'm
still a fat message so I'm trying to
help do it I'm I care about you I don't
care about [ __ ] used to be fat face I
don't care about you
I mean I your your the reason I lost the
weight you had the guy on talking about
notion are no grains on your podcast
that next morning I woke up [ __ ] and
kick the gear no sugar no grains yeah
that's I'm back on that kind of yeah but
no no [ __ ] so what's up let's do
this let's get it going let's [ __ ] do
this
alright let's start off you're up there
around the Westchester area what's the
name of the what's the name of the
grocery store that you go to well I
don't go to it my wife does old school
[Laughter]
couple of well-done steaks and some
canned potatoes I'm kidding I know I'm
not kidding
no I it's called the Chico's is that
like a chain or is it a single oh it's a
very small chain he said it he answered
it very defensively which leads me to
believe it's garbage
no well I'll tell you the Chico's is a
little higher and okay love it's above
stop and shop now I have nothing to get
stop and shop you alright middle rings
but the Chico's you know they're the
chicken salad will not be feed by
anybody whatever whatever that little
whatever that little Mexican lady does
the salad I mean it's the perfect amount
of mayonnaise and she shreds that
chicken like it's a [ __ ] burrito and
Rosarito Mexico it's it's great so yeah
you pick up items like that at the
grocery store the u.s. if you don't go
you give specific instructions I assume
of what you want brought back to the
house I I do now that since December
because I don't have sugar I don't have
grains I don't have dairy or legumes so
yes okay now she knows my [ __ ] so she
just gets my stuff yeah all right let's
step back what would you do lunch meat
from like a debt would you go to the day
to shop right or do you go to I get now
before the diet let's assume
because masquerade you're putting on now
all right let's keep that out of let's
go to the heart of it it looks like he's
drinking a grape soda right now I
suppose every questions gonna be well
actually now I have fresh-squeezed mango
juice you're among friends here all
right I'll make me call the manager at
the Chico's and get him on I yeah I
don't I don't I don't gets me stuff and
makes it I have eggs every day you know
with some type of leftover or something
I hate the leftovers too that's my thing
I just make you with the leftovers and I
recently don't even need a breakfast I
wait as long as I can okay a breakfast
at 1:00 o'clock yeah and what frequency
does your family pre diet and what
frequency does your family have
breakfast for dinner that was all my
list to you [ __ ] what was the
last time you had breakfast for dinner
last week
but last week but yeah no I that's the
first time we had it in probably a long
time years mm-hmm
pandemic rules you can bend a little bit
the first thing it was it was definitely
pandemic like let's let's have but I
have nothing against breakfast for
dinner like a senator if I'm being
honest if I'm being honest we had it
last week but that was the first time in
a long time I think she's the first time
she's ever cooked it like my wife
doesn't [ __ ] around she cooks meals like
she loves that she's old school she's
like her mom and her grandmother she
gets it she goes down she'll get a
[ __ ] lamb shifu uni we have dinner
every night at 5:30 we sit at the table
furniture is from the 50s our glasswares
from the [ __ ] 50s you know there's a
record playing it's it's real
yeah that's 14 classy yeah yeah we have
dinner dinner you know every night yeah
breakfast for dinner three things three
things it's a meat it's like a potato or
in a vegetable it's old school very old
yeah yeah what do you blow does she play
why you guys are eating it's not like
genuine or anything like that is it
we have Frank Sinatra there you go Elvis
Presley okay we have a little Foo
Fighters we have a White Stripes album
we put on what's about and I my personal
album Kelly Clarkson Christmas album
you'll play that now you'll play that in
April May I'll play that I'll play then
fourth of July you know we're so close I
know even the Foo Fighters are any of
you but still that's a very classy setup
know if you're playing Christmas music
for dinner on a Tuesday in July you're
[ __ ] trash I'm sorry there's no way
around it also I respect that breakfast
for dinner is a dad thing dude I didn't
know what breakfast for dinner was until
my parents got divorced I wonder from my
dad's for the first time and he like
rolled out the scram B eggs and I was
like I don't know I don't know everybody
else is crying I got [ __ ] french
toast it's young let's see I got you
know you just reminded me two before the
pandemic me and my son I would take him
Oh twice a month we'd go to the diner
the fountain diner we sit at the bar and
they all know him we sit at the bar and
we do have breakfast he'll get pancakes
I usually get a steak or the prime rib
cuz it's pretty good at that diner and
the waitress the way to come over they
love them every time he answers I think
I'm like I'll never mind he's classy
then he goes I sit down I get the prime
rib at the prime rib at this [ __ ]
place you brought the chart I'm telling
you dude the fountain diner you don't
know it's old-school diner dude
couple of mesh little gravy let's do it
yeah I'm very [ __ ] oh I like it's the
50s I like when people when you went to
a diner and there was somebody back
there who like your grandmother cooking
the [ __ ] oh yeah it's not like some
[ __ ] [ __ ] pancake house or some [ __ ]
diner in Manhattan wherever you know
it's [ __ ] ganache I'm knocking this
place has been there it looks like a
little cottage you know what I mean
and the food that [ __ ] changes every day
it's not the same [ __ ] menu soup is
different every day and it's every I've
never gotten a bad meal at this place
it's and like the ladies that work that
come over and then no Max and they talk
to him and he hangs out and we read the
paper we go through that then we play
cards it's it's a very old school that's
all I can actually tell me - wise guy I
sit at the counter I remember you'll
wake up the Fed that are sleeping out
front I do remember back in the day when
I lived up here the first time before I
did comedy that New York diners used to
be so much [ __ ] better they used to be
awesome
a little place when I was a kid in
Boston they used to have the Paul Revere
diner down the street the donut shop
next door was a real like they had the
little stools and you sat at the thing
and a little a cup of coffee but the cup
was like four inches thick yeah
now you could kill somebody with it
mm-hmm you know they made that you could
see the guy making the donut some fat
guy with an apron and he always smelled
like though you doing over there gonna
say huh huh exactly yeah yes
there you go so good stuff Kippy go
ahead has anyone in your family ever
owned a Camaro I bet you he has it's not
a yes I've met no one in my family has
ever owned a Camaro all right hold on
z28 no one in my family's ever owned a
z28 how about a car with t-tops Trans Am
I'm gonna tell you I did own a car with
t-tops it was a 280zx it was a Mazda
Mazda it's uh it's the highest positive
back in the day and it had about it was
like um like a little racing car you
know the sports car yeah so I went that
road now believe me I would love to have
gone I'm not gonna be lie to you
I would love to have gotten a muscle car
like a Camaro yeah I just I don't like I
don't have the ability to [ __ ] drive
something like that cuz I'll I'll smash
into it I had a motorcycle for a year
and I [ __ ] went down twice I was like
I can't do this I don't I don't know I
I'm [ __ ] too stupid to ride this
thing you know that's dangerous
especially in New York a motorcycle you
gotta be that guy you gotta be the
person that can really focus and do the
right thing
I put headphones on I'm driving I
figured I just turned the wheel like
what he's got his Kelly Clarkson on the
Queensboro Bridge taking a header so you
know I've never owned a Camaro or any
car like that okay I'm sorry do you
change your own oil I do not but but I
do know how to fair enough I learned how
to and I'm not because I have a
snowblower and I had to learn how I you
know now granted I paid somebody to do a
lot of my stuff but I know how to do it
you don't I mean yes I know how to do
that as a no blowers classy my dad is a
snow blower and he treats it like it's
one of his [ __ ] kids man when you're
outside in the [ __ ] 2-footer last
year and you're looking at the lady
across the street with a [ __ ] wood
shovel baby yeah that was me as a kid
though I had to shovel my neighbor had
one and I was like snow like [ __ ]
brutal you rich piece of [ __ ] yeah there
lie back out as a nine year old my uncle
actually for a housewarming gift gave it
to me hey that's a good house we're good
yes his friend was selling it that lived
up here he dropped it off [ __ ] great
we'll use the ones a bit trashy I feel
he couldn't spring stole that he stole
that offer some landscapers [ __ ] try
it it's gonna heaven take a gas in it to
Bobby you turkeys whose it was brand
there's blood on it I guess
you say that is that again I don't I
shouldn't operate these things the first
day I got it we had a massive snowstorm
I go down my I'm [ __ ] loving it right
down the middle the snows going where
it's done I go right over to my neighbor
Delores she's you know 70 something and
I'm going up the thing and her daughter
comes up Bobby don't don't don't don't
like what she's like no we we pay guy
Tonto to come and do it he's already
been paid so don't please he let him
he's got a plow I was like okay because
if he could just get her paper it's down
somewhere just find it and she just
wants her paper that's all I can
absolutely so I go down with my
snowblower all of a sudden I found her
[ __ ] paper alright I should I showed
up it looks [ __ ] shredded like
[ __ ] FBI documents I'm saying I go
here's your paper
the lady goes put that in your act she
shut the door in my face
[ __ ] all right is there do you
apparently own in your shed a garage and
the back of some is there any broken
lawn care equipment a weed whacker that
doesn't turn over a push mower that's
old nothing no I have I pay a guy to do
it yeah I pay around 80 year old Italian
guy though of course literally wobbles
when he I think he's got one leg and I
tell him you know I told him at last
thing I said get all the poison ivy
because we're having a party get all the
points okay okay and he comes back he's
got all the poison ivy like he just
picks it up with his hand yeah and I
come up and he I walk up and he puts his
hand out I shake his hand I go what hand
did you grab the poison ivy with he was
like this one I had poison ivy for
[ __ ] free weights a backpack and he
turn right
eyelash book like my lilac tree last
week which I'm very upset about he cut
it down I used to do it all the time
when I was a landscaper people would
freak the [ __ ] out I just [ __ ] mulch
over a bunch of flowers that I shouldn't
kid screamed at by the owner
I'm so mad there's grass out front there
you know it's you supposed to let it
grow we planted it this [ __ ]
[ __ ] trimmed it
like a marine head I am tell you click
on my little baby lilac bush she took
out for two years ago right in the front
I put forget it I don't I get [ __ ]
angry I can't fire him because he's 79
and he's Italian that I got no I don't
want to you know what I mean
yeah don't what the mob up there looking
for you huh now I just feel I like the
guy you know I'm gonna [ __ ] throw him
on his ass
do you uh you currently owner have you
ever owned direct TV or satellite
television I would never unless I was in
the woods and that was the only option
would I ever get a [ __ ] satellite
stuff if I see a satellite on somebody's
roof garbage that's [ __ ] garbage I
want to rip it off I remember in the 80s
and 90s dudes had like the humor they
had the huge satellite and something
would happen and you'd have to turn it
like you'd have to mm-hmm
that was also like every time you went
there because like one out of you know
200 people had it so you'd go over your
buddy's house and he'd hand you this
[ __ ] remote that looks like it came
from [ __ ] Star Wars oh my god oh [ __ ]
am I supposed to turn on MTV let's go no
local channels you couldn't get the game
or find out what the [ __ ] weather is
gonna be like tomorrow yeah but nobody
knows how to use the [ __ ] thing
either mm-hmm it's like get the little
year to buy it or we'll buy it I don't
know how we'll call them oh [ __ ] me go
[ __ ] yourself right now yeah I'd rather
watch something on my phone my phone as
anyways what do you have up there you
got you guys okay I know it's only
satellite we can only get so you got a
deal you signed a five five-year
agreement for 29.99 he's all I have
outside what is it Time Warner is that
respect your horizon Verizon right
that's new money stuff right there
Verizon Amani rockin FiOS up there look
at this [ __ ] money bags over we're
doing around 800 up and around nine
down right now on the internet I don't
know what that means the [ __ ] does that
mean
that means most people are running like
50 up 50 down how do you know upload
speeds download speed you just go too
fast calm and it'll tell you what you're
running on your [ __ ] or speed test calm
and yeah this is this is a gigabyte I
got the gigabyte Internet up here you
get the 5 g 5g he only knows one
buzzword and he tries to throw it in a
conversation so just ignore him Bobby
it's what they say cause the Coronas 5
yeah Bill Gates at Bill Gates ok have
you or anyone in your family ever skied
in jeans yes that's a yes that ain't no
it is not yes a pair of warm up pants or
something
sledding also counts you have sledding
at [ __ ] come on dude I just let all
the night yeah I got a six-year-old oh
yeah when I was now what are we talking
in my we do in my life your whole life
ever walk yeah so as he lifts and does
he live I've only skied five times okay
one time I know I had a I was with my my
girlfriend at the time bugged me we're
gonna go skiing I was like I [ __ ]
hate skin finally got me on there and we
bought all the outfits so I know that ok
I remember I ski cuz I remember I skied
down I got to the bottom of the mountain
I was like this is so [ __ ] awesome
I'm glad you talked me into it and she
was standing like this she goes we have
to go I'm like what are you talking [ __ ]
her pants she got food poisoning and she
[ __ ] in her [ __ ] ski in his Jesus
Christ like a whole thing on so she had
a it was like a [ __ ] Dutch oven
[Laughter]
who you dating Roseanne what the [ __ ]
she she was actually I was the worst
rented a cabin and she had you stop
dating her I would she had g-string
underwear so she was just [ __ ] into
a split note to it I had this I had a
clean it was like a litter it was a
cable splitter she only bought like two
pairs of three pairs underwear sheesh it
through all three that was trying to
clean them in the
this dude that's yeah that's life [ __ ] I
would have [ __ ] left the hotel hey
Jerry I don't know if I would do that
for my wife
yeah I would have said I got a wife and
kid back in Staten Island roll hit the
bricks sweetheart and I can't do this
anymore
ah yeah I didn't marry her that's my
wife actually that is dawn now I did I
did go skiing when I was in when I got
out of juvie and rehab I they put you in
a always a way to start this is cool put
you in special three weeks ago when I
went back to high school they put you in
you didn't just go back in you had to go
to like mr. Lyons class and it was me it
was his tall girl look like big bird
from the project's dad
[ __ ] chick with big tits ski bunny
from California type girl two Korean
girls and they took a skiing for some
mr. Lyons was like we're gonna field
trip
we went skiing and I remember I think I
had jeans on then because I I wasn't a
skier as in high school as a field trip
yeah the jeans the jeans are a dead
giveaway that you're not as here Molly
so I just remember the two Korean girls
were just giggling the whole way down me
and the ski bunny were going down and
then the the the tall girl she looked
like really tall like big bird from the
projects she didn't know what she was
doing she just pointed her skis straight
down and she was too close just bonded
so she was doing 90 just whacking trees
the whole time and we were just yelling
pizza and then she just wiped out and
slid down the mountain on her face and
we all had to leave I remember that
Jesus cry would say yes I would have I
would have
that's a tough look that's gonna that's
a blemish in the file right there hates
I hate skiing though I hate skiing two
people either bowling I don't mind a
bowling because it's inside there's
other [ __ ] to do but skiing is an
elitist it's it's it's a cross between
elite
in white trash it is and they and their
we're yeah they're wearing these
flamboyant [ __ ] outfits you know it's
it's yeah yeah
just these [ __ ] these dads with their
sons no but is there no not at all
look at this brick when it's [ __ ] bad
who loves them [ __ ] pieces haha
I took my kid snow tubing this year last
year two years ago no I broke my ribs
it's [ __ ] no that's right I forgot
about that picked up a lot of velocity
going down that hill well they should
wait people before they've got a
mountain on a latex tube that sounds
like you got a lawsuit going Oh buddy I
sued the [ __ ] out of I mean I'm talking
dude this is just a red balloon that
stops you at the end I went past these
mats I went in the air the balloon was I
popped yeah I was going into the highway
I'm Bobby two towns over
yeah got stuck in an e-zpass a next day
though the [ __ ] [ __ ] I tasted
it I instagrammed it and I tagged a
minute that I [ __ ] broke my ribs and
he came to the room with fresh-baked
bear claws bagels chocolate regular
milks and a bag of doughnuts and a bag
of muffins this I mean the box was this
big mm-hmm and he he gave it to me and
he gave me free everything passes and
dinner and he knew I mean I [ __ ] as
soon as I had the doughnut yeah they're
lawyers saw you coming from a mile away
they were sitting they were sitting in a
big a big Oh table and they're like have
you seen the size of them send them some
sugary treats all from two chocolate
crawlers and keep it back yeah see if he
makes it
I did that's good fasten you got
have you ever warned a fake turtleneck a
mock turtle vacuum yeah
under a sweater or that's not it's just
a little little thing I my mother got me
one for Christmas one year and I
despised them so much the words elude me
garbage absolutely garbage it's like
just go and get the turtleneck [ __ ]
you look like Mary Tyler Moore you mock
turtle I hate the word mock - yeah mock
turtleneck what does that mean it means
not a yeah yeah well just call it be
creative come up with a douche neck yeah
yeah yeah who gave that your mommy your
mother-in-law my mom your mom okay um
one time I wasn't it sorry go Bobby I
don't have a mother-in-law I have I've
had stepfathers but no oh I did have him
oh no she's dead
your mom's like your wife yes my wife's
mom is dead yes okay unfortunately she
was a pissah she was a real turtle it
was a pisser when she was dying no she
really was I mean I loved that that that
as well yeah yeah yeah yeah and her when
she was dying and she was like lookit
I'm not going to hospice I'm not
quitting smoking I'm not eating I'm
eating whatever the [ __ ] I want so she
would just sit at the kitchen table most
of the day in the negligee you know just
sit there and she'd smoke and I remember
she was eating lamb or cake and she
would fall asleep so she would light the
table on fire so they just they put
tinfoil on hallouwe table so when she
fell asleep it's just fall on the dude
I mean that's old school that's all it's
[ __ ] for his old school [ __ ] Foley
zu got you up I can go
have you ever going on vacation to
colonial William did are you [ __ ]
kidding I thought that was the next
[ __ ] question
was asking Jesus Robert Kelly have you
ever taken your family to Colonial
Williamsburg if you have you are garbage
I don't know what the [ __ ] please don't
tell me if I'm garbage before you answer
the question because I don't want I
don't want any I want to be garbage if
I'm garbage you understand mm-hmm I
don't know where colonial will where is
Williamsburg what is vinya it's like
what people the Northeast think is like
you know Miami it's like in real
colonial is that where they have the
strip of hotels on the beach no no no
South Beach Miami Ocean City Maryland
Ocean City Allen maybe yeah that's trash
there called secrets yes it's like a bar
and nightclub in the water like you said
in waist-deep water yes secrets is that
[ __ ] town is gahbage secrets dude
secrets is bad I never went when people
would be like high school cousin we're
going to secrets and I'm like I'd rather
go to hedonism than [ __ ] we always
grew up we always grew up going down to
the South Jersey Shore for vacation and
then one year for some reason my mom
said we gotta go to Ocean City Maryland
and I remember being down there for like
two hours and being like yo let's get
the [ __ ] out of this place yeah thanks
it's weird it looks like it's looked
like before they built South Beach they
built this just to see what it would
look like yeah it's like the prototype
for a cool city yeah they just let
people move into it wasn't done yet to
go Ben you need to go back in the oven
for a couple minutes [ __ ] garbage the
hotels a [ __ ] we do the same thing went
to some shitty motel and it was just a
bunch of hillbillies and go-carts come
up like yo let's get yeah this place is
strange yeah I don't like when you go to
hotel and people are bringing their own
coolers in oh that's a bad look man
that's another one has my family done
that for sure yeah it's like you can't
just go get a
you have to have one at your [ __ ]
reach in your every second in a ready
Igloo cooler than it's not massive the
core yeah a faded righty google Igloo
cooler yeah um but we did colonial
williamsburg it's bad it's like it's
owned by anheuser-busch or something
it's just like it's all just beer yeah
the Clydesdales are down there that's
where they keep the big Clydesdales and
miser commercials it's all just a scheme
to drink Budweiser I don't even know
about I've never heard it I didn't even
know it existed so right now it's like
where people dress up like old-timey
like you know like Thomas Terkel oh yeah
there's a party it's all Colonial
Williamsburg yeah it was like yeah
that's I mean I don't mind it the black
you know that [ __ ] but the clothes back
then everybody's dick smelled and ah
could you imagine going down on a girl
like getting hot and bothered in them
you shoot you're in a barn and you take
it it just smells like piss hey I
couldn't watch Deadwood because of that
they stink people almost a [ __ ] stump
I can't take that that was before toilet
paper right before any yeah I mean what
is day what a day you I mean there's so
many questions about that time of this
country like what I mean periods poop
you know all kinds of [ __ ] what did you
guys do anything pre refrigeration pre
ice cubes free pre air conditioning
pretty showers must've [ __ ] sucked
unless you lived in a lake it must the
[ __ ] suck I mean Brad though teeth
such bad mouth for short aerials Sarah I
mean just just losing you're better off
losing your teeth that's the only way to
have okay teeth I want to say this
somebody's wife they loved their mouths
and [ __ ] bear never mind a hooker
damn it probably couldn't even get much
worse they were probably all just bad oh
my god
yeah tough love but who knows man I'd
like to find out we could be wrong we
could be wrong sure
they could have a something back then I
just don't know what it was I know a lot
of talcum powder going around the house
it's like a pound cake by the end of the
day all right I got one take you this
coming October what kind of candy are
you guys at your cuz your suburbs what
kind of candy are you giving out on on
Halloween good question good question
what is Bobby this is a big gauge of
your character now okay here's the deal
I live in a dead neighborhood what
happened you know what that is yeah
there's not a lot of people don't come
or they the kids go else like it was not
a lot of foot traffic you eat a lot of
Easter candy or you'd allow Halloween
this might make me garbage because what
we do as we go to a better neighborhood
they bust you in and you know the people
of that neighborhood are walking around
going oh look at look who's getting out
of the car look who's getting out of
there not that garbage Market do you
park in somebody else's driveway just
pulling Camaro in the front yard we're
friends with this couple they're really
cool and they have a little kid party so
we go over there and then we do the hole
and it's un-fuckin'-believable
but I mean it's a great neighborhood
yeah I mean my kids look loads up his
bag but we do put on the front we put
trick-or-treat sneakers
Reese's and three sneakers treats table
sneakers we give everybody nike airs
like in air max one over again we give
we give air max ones and we give away
duffel bags like Jordan duffel bags
that's funny dude I remember getting a
member getting a king-size crunch bar
one time and I thought we went to the
nice neighborhood got a king-size crunch
bar dude I thought I was in heaven
yeah they'll break it off at 20 over at
the nice [ __ ] haver
once in a while yeah but there was
always the idea of do you go to the
really rich neighborhoods or do you go
to like the town houses so you can get
more doors you know what I mean there
was there was a system to it well in New
York City we didn't know this we when we
bought our place in New York we were
very we love Halloween
I love always loved it and we we we got
our candy and we went outside and we sat
on the stoop and we were like come here
and it was just me and my chick you know
go come in and they were just looking as
like no we didn't know that they went to
the bodegas they go to the stores yeah
yeah I didn't know that they didn't see
some bald guy like me with a bucket of
candy come into my come on it's right
down the alleyway don't worry
two doors I got a buzz you in
come on in I wouldn't want to raise a
kid dude having a kid in New York then
their trick-or-treat in like a
barbershop it's the weirdest [ __ ] to me
from growing up in the suburbs it's like
you know they're running it they're
running in and out of Duane Reade's they
get it they get a crunch bar it's it's
stupid
yeah I don't know I didn't like it one
[ __ ] bit I did not like it at all
it's kind of stupid up here it's like
when I was a kid I'd have to [ __ ] sex
excuse me huh gosh
you know but yeah yeah I remember one
year by [ __ ] some kids took my bag
and this happened I had I cause you had
a pillowcase yeah because they didn't
have these you know think of all this
[ __ ] now he's got a kid and it's gonna
light on it and it gets crazy [ __ ] and
all the parents have lights and blah
blah blah and they have hot chocolate
and someone drinking and they're it's
really uestions when I was a kid day I
was out by myself with a with a [ __ ] my
pillowcase and I filled that [ __ ] and
went home my grandmother went through it
all and then let me go at it as much I
wanted till I [ __ ] got sick and then
you went to bed yeah good times baby
good times now my wife is a gift you can
have two it's like let the [ __ ]
camera guy just worked his ass off
daughter daughter like a traveling
salesman let him get a couple of
Snickers you know what I mean
one night go to [ __ ] get a cavity I
don't give a [ __ ] do you then yeah grow
up I don't care oh that's funny Bobby do
you currently or have you ever owned a
metal detector it looks like a metal
detector guy doesn't yeah he could be
concealed on the lakeshore front early
in the morning car it was a problem with
all these questions
well I've wanted a lot of he's just -
garbage - ever actually get them there's
just a something in me that won't let me
get them I'm surprised you know the
metal detectors my son has a toy one of
course yeah but it's not real but I've
always I've always wanted to get a medal
today I always just want to find a
bullet or a bow buckle from the Civil
War did I have one as a kid I got one a
RadioShack for 149 99 mm my dad hated I
begged for months finally got one and we
didn't find [ __ ] that thing did not
third you can put it on the side of a
car and it still wouldn't go off that
thing did not work there's a lot there's
a lot you got to get the real guns
you're gonna get the dumb stick to scoop
the scoop you better get the scoop but
then there's like another magnet you
have to have I didn't know that so they
had a TV show on Fermi with these
[ __ ] two rednecks we ask people you
know they'd find little plots that had
War battles on it back can we please and
they the guy go ahead and they go around
the [ __ ] fan of look at this corn is
that what it is go to commercial oh my
god and you'd have to wait and then it
would be a [ __ ] penny from yeah Pepsi
cap or something like that
yeah do we saw a guy down here at the
beach where it's like a blue-collar
resort town and he was like walking
through and everybody's like get the
[ __ ] out of here yeah dude I can't bring
myself to get one but I do I do
geocache what's that
it's trash it sounds real bad Bobby it
don't sound good come on come on it have
to do with the Geo Tracker if it does
you're in trouble
it's an app that you download and people
put little treasures all around the
country in the world and it will show
you on the map
where there are like this right near you
right across the street from you there's
and you have to find it and then you
open it and you see what it is and
sometimes you take something leave
something sometimes you just sign your
name and it's been there you've probably
walked by it a hundred times it's been
the fate years you know and I mean but
it's just you know these little
treasures so it's almost like sounds
like you need another hobby have another
something Bobby Jesus no I didn't word
stuff you in a [ __ ] locker the tune
in to our podcast with are you a loser
[Laughter]
I'm actually the president I'm the
president of our chapter it's great that
sounds a lot like pokeyman go to baby
yeah I do with my kid I don't do it by
myself I don't go out there with a
bandana and a compass is like choppers
okay he's got bottles he's got cutoff
jeans on in the work boots time I'm on a
[ __ ] push scooter [ __ ] a Nalgene
bottle with stickers I [ __ ] I bring
my kid you [ __ ]
it was just doing his soul to do he kind
of knew you you kind of knew he was
gonna get beat up he's God you were like
and we were like what you're like [ __ ]
it's tomato soup and that coffee cup
dude
alright man
I got one hit happy I know your wife she
said your wife does most of the cooking
I'm sure this is a no okay I'm sure this
is a no but I could be thorough I have
to ask you all right have you ever had
have you ever made a dish where the
recipe required crushed potato chips as
an ingredient
you know we're a food that has that no
but I'm not gonna [ __ ] deny that it
doesn't make it to the sandwich if
you're not putting chips on a sandwich
that you're making at home you're a that
much better no I don't do it because it
seems a little rich to me my daughter
sure yeah I mean it makes it that much
better not my kid last week we had Taco
Tuesday I didn't have the taco shell a
head of lettuce shell and he took one of
my no grain tortilla chips and broke it
up into my taco and it made it taste
like it was a like a taco it's a taco
salad Bobby you never had that you never
had that taco salad I think that's a
that's a garbage Philly thing I think
taco dip was big there's a lot of Hidden
Valley Ranch involved in that taco sound
yeah I remember one time me and Jay he
could be he would travel and I was just
trying to get home at a six hour drive
and he begged me to go to Taco Bell in
the middle of the night and he and this
fat [ __ ] got a taco salad and I remember
we left we left and I he didn't give us
the sour cream and he made me go back oh
my car smelled like a [ __ ] [ __ ] taco
and then that fat [ __ ] fell asleep cuz
he ate too much it's supposed to step
but I was just throwing M&Ms at his head
if you're do you think that's a garbage
you move if you're driving with somebody
somewhere do you mind if that person if
the persons in shotgun if they fall
asleep think that's trash you got to ask
you got ass no no that's your
responsibility you shouldn't even ask
responsibility on yourself to the gig
done that's what I'm he's agreed yeah
he's over agreeing with you yeah you say
you shouldn't do it at all
you shouldn't even ask because then the
burdens on me to be the [ __ ] to say
no stay up your job if I'm driving us to
the gig your job is this just not sleep
this isn't yes this isn't the boat bus
depends on who it is though it's Joe
DeRosa you might want him to take a nap
huh it was mouth rest for a couple
minutes you know I mean well let's Foley
he goes into sugar coma so I can't
really help it we hit a Wendy's and he
doesn't make it out of the park
oh yeah Patrice we're driving over
McGinty yeah you know we would stop in
every five minutes because of his
diabetes he had a piss and then we
finally stopped to get gas yeah I come
out of the bathroom myself he's got a
honey bun in in yoohoo in his hand I'm
like we're never gonna get home I was
actually on my list how do you feel
about you who you eat fanny you who I am
not really nah chocolate milk get a
chunk of milk if you're gonna go chuck
em up why are you gonna go some strange
Dutch [ __ ] Denmark [ __ ] Java where
did it come from
it's like Newark it's not it's not fancy
European it's gone it's like laboured
water yeah it's like they did they got
it out of like some hose in a factory
yeah it's not good yeah it's a weird
consistency it's a weird consistency you
have to shake it and it gets this bubbly
watery yeah it's [ __ ] good [ __ ]
and also like chocolate milk it's not
like chocolate milks like 25 cents a
glass like it's not like you're saving
money buying the you little yeah it's
stupid it's stupid
what's the chocolate milk situation at
your house what do you do to you what do
you have how does Europe know not the
part of the squeeze what kind of sweet
what's the brain oh she's very nice okay
but chocolate milk is I make it he likes
when I make it cuz I [ __ ] screw you
can see the milk go up like an inch oh
so that just answered the question this
is a big this is a big theme on the
podcast you put milk in first and then
the track you put milk in but you leave
an inch okay and then you put the chalk
ago so you can see how much chocolate
you put in yes don't go up you're like
all right that's enough chocolate I know
boom boom boom and then you chocolate
they'd have to worry about it this is
gold knows it the reverse way he puts
them the chocolate in first like a
lunatic and then the middle savage you
know that means this stuff's gonna get
stuck into the cop when the milks in
there prevents you from getting stuck to
the bottom that's where you got a spoon
for
no I know what you use the spoon for I'm
not sitting there using my [ __ ]
pinkie I'm but when you put the milk in
first then the chocolate it doesn't go
directly to the bottom and stick yes
chocolate and it sticks to that cup it's
hard you're never gonna get all the
chalk to Grand Canyon down there you got
lucky you gotta blend it in you know you
you're wasting it I don't know if that's
why he lies this body that's walking
garbage that's why well that's like not
having water in the toilet bowl you
should we just hit the [ __ ] I know yeah
just stain it every time wait order on
your toilet Pole all right I think I
only got one or two more go ahead Kippy
jeans have you ever used duct tape to
fix to fix your car even temporarily or
anything now no but I did use a stick
once what I had a 67 Chevy Impala and
the fan belt fell off and back then cars
you could you know you didn't there was
nothing in them it was just the engine
and you know it was very there's nothing
yeah and I got a stick and I [ __ ]
Jimmy decided on and I got back to the
Jewish camp I was working as a lifeguard
[Music]
that was an onion that just kept on
peeling I have one last question I was
debating going one or two ways on this
but I think I'm gonna ask you do you
have any psychics in your family any
mediums in your family anybody who says
that they can connect to the spirits on
the other side
he does he does all right so now what do
you by Romanian I'm a [ __ ] Irish
Italian from Boston we don't [ __ ]
believe in that [ __ ]
they're either cat with a that's like
down shut up so [ __ ] christ
you know you believe in Jesus Christ you
shut your face you don't talk about sex
yeah you don't masturbate molested yeah
when you masturbate you [ __ ] you know
you grow your dead grandmother's
watching he's gonna take the head and
you don't do it when anybody knows on an
airplane that's the thing I've learned
too
that's true the fact that people go down
I see these people go down of these
little psychic places in the West
Village
there are dude what are you doing I
wanna know how the [ __ ] they're paying
rent oh dude it they're not oh you don't
know about the gypsies in New York City
cuz they're [ __ ] dude they got scams
really yeah dude they squat they just
take apartments yeah some of them
they're just in like a telephone booth
sighs little room of like if they're so
strange-looking
who's getting turned on when I walk by
those things for some reason if the
girls like kind of hot yeah there's
never there's never a heifer out front
saying always like a cute Romanian chick
yeah there's always this some chick out
she says hi she looks attainable she's
not too hot she's attainable like she
might be her job yeah and then you go
back there and they're like let me and
then they get real serious and let me
let me ask you uh shut up Josh I just
want to go there and go Sheppard they'll
[ __ ] stab you yes women will find
they got a boot knife they'll [ __ ]
bleed you out and [ __ ] use your blood
for a potion I need I need blood of fat
man holy [ __ ] lay down on the car do
not [ __ ] with gypsies dude they'll take
your blood and throw coins in it to
[ __ ] make it more money
don't [ __ ] Alchemy's yeah we're leaf
clovers are glowing out of my stomach
that's great ma'am Bobby that's all we
have for you man kid you got anything
else no that's it buddy thank you so
much man we appreciate it and I say no
naughty what first of all this guy had
breakfast for dinner last week within
the within the week he's at breakfast
for dinner that's a big no-no he orders
steak at a diner that ain't looking good
he orders prime rib that's a story he's
skied in his jeans when he was a kid I
don't know I'm saying classy I'm saying
you're classy body honestly with two
dinners the Canadian i'll give you not
garbage he's not classy I'll give
you might do a diner you know our [ __ ]
is not seeing your kids okay not
gorgeous or during prime rib at a diner
that is trash that sounds pretty good to
me your call so trash and may or may not
be having a heart attack during the
podcast I want to name it that diner
fountain diner it's not a Denny's you
[ __ ] is one of them it's one
family
it's a [ __ ] been there for a hundred
years fair enough now you go to a diner
you get the omelet you get the chicken
fingers you garbage were you garbage if
you try to order a nice cut of meat and
then say you're trash go to a steak
house Bobby
[ __ ] you I'm gonna take you to the diner
one night I'm gonna get you the prime
rib it's [ __ ] good yeah I'm trash
dude I am garbage I'll sit there and
seconds don't wanna be you as the
fountain diner served the baked potatoes
in the tin foil because that's how I get
the vibe they do probably a great on the
covenant-- tinfoil is nice too maybe on
a cast-iron skillet coming out Oh Bobby
I doubt there's anything but is anything
you want the folks out there to know
that they might not already know you got
Kelly and Cal to show on patreon every
night seven o'clock with doing that you
did it last week I'd like to have you on
it too or maybe both maybe both you guys
come on and plug your show you could be
hilarious Sam love guys are I'm glad
you're doing this is great thank you
buddy we appreciate you being on ladies
and gentlemen Sir Robert Kelly Kippy
anything you're Tom again just please
rate review subscribe we appreciate all
the support so far we've got it off no
new reviews and subscribers every day we
really appreciate it please tell a
friend and if you everybody's writing
and commenting comments and sending them
like DMS and stuff just urge questions
that they want to submit just email and
so are you garbage at gmail.com that way
we'll get there they won't get lost and
all the alerts Bobby you guys start
doing this with real famous people
okay that's enough over this is the new
you what are you talking we just read 97
of your credits Bobby what are you
talking about this guy's done everything
under the Sun despite the prime rib at
the diner alright dude go get a wet
towel put it on the dock you [ __ ]
christ
I'll see you guys I go get it I'm gonna
go in a couple of spins put in